♪ ♪
>> WE ARE NOT HAPPY WITH THAT
WHOLE SITUATION BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IT COULD’VE BEEN STOPPED
AT THE SOURCE, STOPPED QUICKLY,
AND IT WOULDN’T HAVE SPREAD.
WE THINK THAT SHOULD HAVE
HAPPENED.
WE WILL LET YOU KNOW, BUT WE ARE
DOING SERIOUS INVESTIGATIONS.
>> Martha: PRESIDENT ROUHANI
JUST MOMENTS AGO AS HEALTH
OFFICIALS AND CHINA SAY THE LAST
COVID-19 PATIENCE HAVE BEEN
RELEASED FROM THE HOSPITAL.
A MAJOR MILESTONE FOR THE CITY,
WHERE THE PANDEMIC FIRST BEGAN,
BUT THE ANNOUNCEMENT COMES AS
CHINA MAY HAVE HAD UP TO 50
TIMES MORE CASES THAN THEY HAVE
ADMITTED, OR REPORTED OFFICIALLY
OFFICIALLY.
THE ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL
TELLING FOX NEWS "WE DON’T KNOW
THE REAL NUMBERS TODAY, BUT WE
DO KNOW 80,000 INFECTIONS AND
4,0004,000 DEATH NUMBERS REPORTE
THE COMMUNIST PARTY PROPAGANDA
ARE NOT EVEN REMOTELY CLOSE."
HERE NOW IS LINDSEY GRAHAM.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
OBVIOUSLY IT’S VERY DIFFICULT TO
BELIEVE WHAT IS COMING OUT OF
CHINA IN TERMS OF THESE NUMBERS.
I’M GOING TO POP UP THE
POPULATION NUMBERS.
CHINA’S POPULATION 1.4 BILLION.
THEY SAY THEY LOST 4,600 PEOPLE.
THE UNITED STATES HAS
328 MILLION AND WE HAVE BEEN
FULLY TRANSPARENT ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE LOST NEARLY 56,000
RIGHT NOW.
TAKE A LOOK AT WUHAN VERSUS
NEW YORK, WUHAN HAS 11 MILLION
PEOPLE, NEW YORK CITY HAS A
.4 MILLION, 17 DEATHS.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
>> THAT
IS CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY B.S.
HERE’S WHAT WE DO KNOW,
26 MILLION AMERICANS ARE OUT OF
WORK BECAUSE OF THIS VIRUS.
ALMOST 56,000 AMERICANS ARE DEAD
BECAUSE OF THIS VIRUS.
IT CAME FROM CHINA.
I’M NOT SAYING THEY
INTENTIONALLY DID THIS.
MAKE COMBINATION OF GROSS
NEGLIGENCE PLUS WILLFUL
DECEPTION LED TO THIS.
HERE IS MY PLEA TO MY DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES, PLEASE DON’T GIVE
CHINA A PASS FOR THIS PANDEMIC.
WORK FOR ME TO COME BUT HELD
CHINA, NUMBER ONE, FULLY
COOPERATE WITH ANY INVESTIGATION
REGARDING HOW THE VIRUS
ORIGINATED, U.S., AND
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
NUMBER TWO, CLOSE ALL THE WET
MARKETS THAT SYRUP EXOTIC
WALLEYE.
THREE, RELEASED ALL THE
HONG KONG DEMOCRACY ADVOCATES
THAT HAVE BEEN IN JAIL SINCE THE
VIRUS STARTED.
WE ARE GOING TO PUT SANCTIONS ON
CHINA UNTIL THEY DO THOSE THREE
THINGS AND 90 DEMOCRATS.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN VERY SOLID
WHEN IT COMES TO CHINA, PLEASE
DO NOT GIVE THEM A PASS.
>> Martha: WE HAVE HEARD A
NUMBER OF PROPOSALS COMING OUT
OF CONGRESS TO CRACKDOWN ON
CHINA.
ARE THERE TEETH IN THIS?
TELL ME ABOUT THE SANCTIONS.
IF THEY DON’T DO THOSE THREE
THINGS, OR EVEN ONE OF THOSE
THREE THINGS, WHAT WILL HAPPEN?
>> THAT’S A GREAT QUESTION.
WE WILL SEE ASSETS OF CHINESE
OFFICIALS THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR NOT REPORTING THE PANDEMIC.
WE WILL CUT CHINA OFF FROM
INSTITUTIONS, WE WE WILL SHUT DO
VISA, TRAVEL AND TO THE
UNITED STATES FOR CHINESE
STUDENTS.
WE WILL CLOSE OFF AMERICA TO
CHINA, THE CHINESE ECONOMY.
WE WILL MAKE IT HARD FOR THEM TO
DO THIS UNTIL THEY FULLY
COOPERATE, CLOSE THE WET
MARKETS, AND RELEASE THE
HONG KONG DEMOCRACY.
THERE IS A REAL TEETH AND THIS,
BUT THE ONLY WAY IT WILL HAVE
TEETH, IF IT’S BIPARTISAN.
TO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, JOINED
ME AND PRESIDENT TRUMP AND ALL
REPUBLICANS TO SEND A SIGNAL TO
CHINA, BUSINESS AS USUAL IS OVER
UNTIL YOU CHANGE YOUR BEHAVIOR.
>> Martha: IT’S INTERESTING,
THE POLES WE HAVE SEEN SHOW THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE REALLY
WAKING UP TO THIS ISSUE AND THAT
THEY DON’T WANT US TO BE
DEPENDENT ON CHINA ANYMORE.
I FIND THAT FASCINATING.
IT SORT OF REMINDS ME THE MAID
OF THE U.S. A MOVEMENT THAT WAS
AROUND
IN THE LATE 70s, EARLY 80s.
I ACTUALLY HAVE A LITTLE CLIP
FROM ONE OF THOSE JIGGLES THAT I
WILL PLAY.
LET’S PLAY THAT.
♪ ♪
>> Martha: DO YOU REMEMBER
THOSE?
THAT’S THE UNION WORKERS.
I THINK THAT -- I THINK THAT IF
YOU HAVE A REAL MAKE IT IN THE
USA MOVEMENT AND THIS COUNTRY AT
THIS MOMENT, I THINK YOU COULD
GET A LOT OF MOMENTO.
WHY DON’T WE SEE THAT?
>> IT’S CALL THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
HOW DID HE GET TO BE PRESIDENT?
HE SAID I’M GOING TO STAND UP TO
CHINA CHEATING.
I’M GOING TO STAND UP TO THEM
STEALING OUR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST REASONS THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, HE SAW THE
BEHAVIOR OF CHINA TO BE
UNACCEPTABLE.
EVERY OTHER PRESIDENT BEFORE HIM
HAS GIVEN CHINA I PASS.
HE IS NOT GOING TO DO THAT.
I HOPE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WILL
STEP UP AND WORK WITH ME TO MAKE
SURE WE FIND OUT WHAT HAPPENED
IN CHINA.
IF THEY DON’T COOPERATE, THEY
LOSE ACCESS TO THE U.S. ECONOMY.
NUMBER TWO, SHORTLY’S WET
MARKETS.
THIS IS THE THIRD PANDEMIC
COMING FROM WHAT MARKETS.
AS THE WORLD HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON
THE CORONAVIRUS, THEY BEEN
PUTTING EVERYBODY IN JAIL IN
HONG KONG.
ENOUGH WITH CHINA ALREADY.
>> Martha: THE PRESIDENT --
I AGREE WITH YOU.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN VERY
TOUGH ON CHINA WHEN IT COMES TO
THE TRADE DEAL.
HE ALSO SAYS, PRESIDENT XI
JINPING IS MY FRIEND AND I’M NOT
GOING TO DO ANYTHING REALLY
DRAMATIC.
HE IS DEFINITELY HOLDING OUT ON
THAT TRADE DEAL AS ONE LAST
CONNECTION TO CHINA AND THEIR
ECONOMY.
YOU CAN TELL FROM WHAT HE SAID.
>> ONE, THIS GUY IS NOT OUR
FRIEND.
OUR FRIEND WOULD NOT LET THIS
HAPPEN TO SOMEBODY.
A FRIEND WOULD NOT SIT SILENTLY
BY AND PROTECTED THEIR OWN
COUNTRY WHILE THE REST OF THE
WORLD GETS AFFECTED.
CHINA IS SOMEBODY WE HAVE TO DO
BUSINESS WITH.
I WANT A GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEM, BUT THEY HAVE TO EARN IT.
THIS IS A CHANCE FOR THE PARTIES
TO COME TOGETHER.
WE HAVE COME TOGETHER BACK HERE
AT HOME BY PUTTING MONEY ON THE
TABLE TO HELP AMERICANS GET
THROUGH THE CORONAVIRUS.
WE NEED TO COME TOGETHER WHEN IT
COMES TO PUNISHING CHINA TO MAKE
SURE IT DOESN’T HAPPEN AGAIN.
IF THEY GET AWAY WITH IT THIS
TIME, THEY WILL DO IT AGAIN.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
>> Martha: NO DOUBT.
WE HAVE SPENT DECADES WORKING ON
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE WHICH WE
FINALLY ACHIEVED.
I THINK THERE IS A MOVEMENT IN
THIS COUNTRY TO WANT
INDEPENDENCE FROM CHINA AND WE
WILL SEE IF THAT IS WHAT WE GET
AND WE WILL BE WATCHING YOU OR
BILL AS YOU TRY TO GET IT TO
MOVE THROUGH THE PROCESS.
THANK YOU, SENATOR.
>> I HOPE WE HAVE A VOTE ON IT.